I see trees of green red roses too I see
them bloom for me and you and I think to
myself what a wonderful world
ah ah don't clap okay I got that out I
feel good about it you know that song I
think I was born with that song in my
heart that song is constantly just
playing in my soul you know when I look
at the trees I look at white people
walking down no one I see white people
they're all laughing happy with their
like little skateboards or you know I
mean they have their little laptop in
the back backpack and they're happy you
know making deals I feel happy free
they're making deals all the time you
know white people you know yeah but
anyway welcome to another episode of
tiger belly this is a very special very
special episode that we have here I hear
noises that I don't want to hear right
now currently but that's okay that's
okay we can we I can be thrown a
curveball all right so what we have we
got a Gilbert Milan Ghilas Malaga's flat
face
what's up flat face Filipino [ __ ]
oh good today no not today
I like my beautiful island princess
kalila your attitude [ __ ] stinks
today all day every day I'll tell you
that right now and you should look in
the mirror I see [ __ ] really evaluate
your life we got towards here I wish had
a recording of you on the phone with me
while I was in San Francisco for four
days was it it was a whole lot of we are
guests here this is a very rule what
you're doing okay we got George Kimmel
we've got his cousin guys yeah and we
have a very special guest let me say
something right now he gets from Florida
yes he's from Florida and you know
sometimes people from Florida they turn
weird our favorite you know I'd the
Aileen Wuornos what's her name
yeah she's from Florida you know they do
a lot of what's that one drug where they
eat people's faces that's all that's all
that came right yeah that came from
there I think but sometimes good things
come from there you know and there's two
things that have come from there that I
enjoy
one of them's another comic and this is
the other comic right and this comic
right here
I [ __ ] love Bert Kreischer but I only
[ __ ] finally you have no idea how
hard that is is that hard when you said
when you called him flat face I was like
I have so much [ __ ] to talk about that
our best friends Vietnamese secret drunk
one night she goes yeah agents have a
hard time finding sunglasses fall off
their face and bro I lost my [ __ ] I put
my ray-bans on they fell in her mouth
hysteria see that we can't be President
because if on a coin would just be like
a line we do have flat faces but it's
fine is our lien Wallace from Florida or
did she find her weight that's what
Florida is known for people to find
their way to Florida yeah but it's a you
know it's like a moth to a flame
you're right so they all gravitate the
crazies gravitate to either Wisconsin
you have no idea how crazy my I knew in
Florida I knew to dues without tongues
swear a scowl head ask our tongueless
brett whose cow had showered my counter
your buddy radio guy yeah yeah
tongueless brett and hall cow head loves
you I love Colin like you're the guy
that I go into and they're like do you
know we just had in and I go who and
they're like Oh Bobby Lee he's amazing
it because I'm fun at radio cuz I like
to get loose I'm pretty good myself
you're watching pretty amazing some
coffee and I try to be real I [ __ ] on
his couch
it's like [ __ ] what he had us a white
couch yeah
and he goes Margaret Cho sat on this
without any underwear and she goes she
left a little bit of a [ __ ] stain oh wow
I go I want to leave one tool and I did
that an accent and I left a really good
one and then they cut it out in the
frame debt oh really
yeah because my poo is pollutant how did
a whole yeah I don't know you don't know
it'll tell you he's your friend
no just guys I know I'm friends with
somebody they can't talk you just they
just get they morph their way into your
life like you're like you don't have a
tongue hang on let's go yeah yeah yeah
[Music]